hallo mein name ist luca meine damen und
herren ich als youtuber befinde mich
selbstverständlich 24/7 nur in meinem
aufnahme zimmer und kriege gar nicht mit
was draußen in der welt eigentlich so
alles abgeht wie das alles aussieht und
vor allem wie sich tiere anhören von
daher habe ich mir heute eine app
rausgesucht die uns ziel geräusche zeigt
ich soll meine sprache auswählen gackert
ein huhn auf englisch anders als auf
deutsch oder was
[Musik]
optimal entscheidend ich würde sagen wir
kriegen hier erst mal auf zu hause und
haben nun einen hund hund ja der hund
lebt im haus
da
danke für die info das nächste tier
geräusch was wir uns mal anschauen
möchten ist hier die katze katze
jetzt weiß ich wie sich eine katze
anhört dann haben wir hier auch noch
eine maus aus die maus frist these are
also mäuse fressen grundsätzlich nur
käse wenn die durch irgendwelche
kanalisationen unter großstädten
rumlaufen die suchen sich immer direkten
schön käseteller was anders fressen die
gar nicht er kanarienvogel ja kennen die
nicht so sieht jeder kanarienvogel aus
der kanarienvogel ist normalerweise geht
ehrlich das hätte ich da jetzt gar nicht
erkannt das nächste tier was wir hier in
der tiergeräusche app haben ist der hase
naja klicke ich auch mal draußen hase
ist sehr schnell
ok und was noch der hase frist karotten
bei der stücke hören wir uns auch mal an
was sie dazu sagen haben ich schnecke
hat ein gehäuse das sie schützt ich
dachte das wär style bei dem hasen und
bei der schnecke gerade hat die app
leider keine tiergeräusche gemacht
naja ok was wäre auch ein geräusch von
der schnecke leguan unter der kategorie
tiere aus dem zuhause also prämien
laufen überall leguane rum der leguan
lebt anfeuchten orten warum ist er dann
in der zu hause kategorie und was ist
das ziel geräusch von dem leguan ich
komme ich da draußen ich muss doch mal
was macht also dass wir waren jetzt die
tiere die uns in dieser zuhause
kategorie gezeigt wurden
dann haben wir noch viel wir haben noch
bauernhof die musik ist auch wirklich
sehr toll wahnsinn was können wir über
die kuh so lernen die kuh frisst gras
und junkies rauchen gras schwang was ist
da bin ich das schwein frisst alles
mögliche alles klar
wenn ich als kind diese app vorgesetzt
bekommen hätte von meinen eltern und die
app hätte mir gesagt ein schwein frisst
alles mögliche dann hätte ich todesangst
vor schweinen weil ich denken würde dass
die nur noch menschenfressende liegt ja
das wusste ich noch gar nicht
okay das ist ein schaf dass schaaf
tatsächlich mehr bad als ich die haut
des schafes ist mit wolle bedeckt
achte mal dass wer zuckerwatte taube
hatte tauben als sie in der siebten
klasse war haben die mir während der
schulzeit mein komplettes fahrrad folge
schützen
wenn ihr das seht
ja allerdings meine liebe luxus will ich
das heutige video an der stelle jetzt
auch beenden das tut mir leid dass es
ein bisschen kürzer geworden ist als
meiner sonstigen videos allerdings bin
ich gerade erst aus dem urlaub
zurückgekommen und hat sieben stunden
auto gefahren und ich würde sagen wir
machen noch ein tier eben in köthen
die küken jetzt einfach nur ein baby
an der stelle wird das heutige video ist
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren wenn es euch gefallen hat wie ich
auf die geräusche reagiert habe ich hab
so ein ballett knicks hier gemacht und
stellt euch das video hier gefallen hat
dann auch gerne mal einen daumen hoch da
falls sie noch kein abonnent von meinem
kanal seit dann rückt auf abonnieren
unter diesem video und jetzt kommt das
auto